but you are right there are some
questions today that people are raising
about some eyebrow raising comments made
by the president about potential
treatments to fight the corona virus
during yesterday's White House briefing
mr. Trump throughout several potentially
dangerous ideas including using UV light
and disinfectant inside the human body
supposing we hit the body with a
tremendous whether it's ultraviolet or
just very powerful light and I think you
said that hasn't me checked but you're
gonna test it and then I said supposing
you brought the light inside the body
you can which you can do either through
the skin or in some other way then I see
the disinfectant where it knocks it out
in a minute
one minute and is there way we can do
something like that by injection inside
or almost of cleaning the maker of Lysol
is stressing that under no circumstances
should a product like Lysol ever be
administered into the body CBS News
chief medical correspondent dr. Jon
LaPook joins us now good morning Jon can
you set the record straight on the
president's potentially dangerous
suggestion here that ultraviolet light
and disinfectant be used to treat the
virus hi Anthony yeah just because
something works outside of the body
doesn't mean you should bring it inside
the body where it could potentially
cause severe damage
you mentioned Lysol I remember when I
was a medical student there was a young
boy who accidentally drank it and his
esophagus got very scarred I know that
the president said intravenously but
here's the problem as a professional as
a doctor I'm very careful about the
language that I use medicine is an
eternally humbling profession and even
when I think I've said something
perfectly right people can misinterpret
it so the last thing you want is
somebody hearing this hearing this kind
of a statement and then being very ill
themselves and saying you know what I'm
gonna get just give it a try
so you have to be very careful with
language and even when you are careful
people can still miss hear you John the
White House is also touting these new
lab results which have not yet been
peer-reviewed
but they suggest that heat and sunlight
could slow the coronavirus what do we
know about this well we've known that
the virus likes it to be dry and cold
and it doesn't like it when it's hot and
moist so people have wondered gee I
wonder if when it gets warm and moist
and those areas of the country if it'll
just go away or the world in Singapore
though and in other areas of the world
where it's warm and moist the virus is
still out there and and multiplying so
we can't rely on that and one of the
problems again about this suggestion is
people hearing and saying oh go out in
the sunlight and no problem I don't have
to do all the other things the social
distancing and wearing the mask and
things that we have been suggesting a UV
light especially UVC has been used it's
very short weighed then it's and it can
fry the virus but it can also fry the
body it's used for certain skin
conditions UV treatment but again you
have to be very careful about how you do
that all right dr. Jon LaPook thanks
very much